hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es einen grundrezept und
zwar mache ich den wiener boden einmal
in hell und einmal in dunkel der wiener
boden ist eigentlich kennt ihn
wahrscheinlich als biskuitteig das ist
ein sehr feiner boden ein saftiger boden
und ich finde den geschmack nicht total
gut weil da einfach etwas butter mit
dabei ist ich zeige euch heute wirklich
die komplett klassische variante zuerst
einmal die helle variante und später
dann noch die dunkle variante beim
wiener boden ist es so damit die eier
später richtig schön stabil sind
brauchen wir etwas hitze und muss dann
entweder die eier auf dem wasser bei im
wasserbad aufschlagen oder in der
küchenmaschine und ich zeige euch heute
einfach beide möglichkeiten für den
hellen wiener boden worauf ich 320 gramm
eier und zwar sind es sechs eier größe m
200 gramm zucker etwas zitronenschale
april von einer bio zitrone vanille
extrakt eine prise salz 75 gramm mehl 75
g speisestärke und 75 gramm butter ich
mal zuerst einmal die variante in der
küchenmaschine mit hitze funktion da
nehme ich jetzt die kenwood und dafür
gebe ich jetzt die eier komplett in die
küchenmaschine die müssen also dafür
nicht getrennt werden und hierbei dem
rezept ist es ganz wichtig dass ihr
wirklich die mengen ganz genau ab misst
deswegen sage ich euch auch wie viel
gramm eben die eier sind und nicht nur
die eier menge das ist nämlich wirklich
ganz wichtig da kommt jetzt der zucker
noch mit rein das salz dennoch etwas
manila extrakt ich nehme da immer ganz
gerne einfach so einen ganz kleinen
schluck das ist dann etwas ein halber
teelöffel das ist nämlich aus echtem an
in konzentrat und jetzt muss ich die
eier zucker mischung auf 45 grad
einstellen das kann ich jetzt hier an
der küchenmaschine fast aufs grad genau
was die maschine jetzt ganz langsam
erstmal rühren und hier oben kann ich
jetzt auch kontrollieren wann die
temperatur erreicht ist
sobald die 45 grad erreicht sind nämlich
die hitze weg und schlag der zucker
mischung etwa zwei minuten auf höchster
stufe auf in der zwischenzeit kann ich
schon mal die zitronenschale abreiben
und dabei habe ich nur den gelben teil
ab und nicht die waagschale
jetzt ist die eier zuckermasse
aufgeschlagen und jetzt muss ich sie bei
dieser mittel hoher geschwindigkeit so
lange weiter schlagen
diese temperatur wieder ganz runter geht
ich muss jetzt kalt schlagen auf etwa 20
21 grad
die zitronenschale gebe ich jetzt auch
mit dazu und je nachdem was für einen
tag und was für eine torte macht können
jetzt mehr oder weniger zitronenschale
dazugeben oder sie auch komplett
weglassen und das aufschlagen dauert
etwa 10 bis 15 minuten
in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon
um einen bug rahmen vorbereiten und ich
empfehle ich auch immer in back rahmen
zu backen überbacken detail etwas
gleichmäßiger und ihr habt auch eine
kürzere fahrzeit und überkommt nicht
diesen typischen kuppel auf dem kuchen
wahrscheinlich jeder kennt der kuchen
reis einfach nicht ein
debug kamen schlagen kann damit etwas
was für ein und da ist es am besten wenn
ihr so ein strukturiertes backen ihr
habt dann fangt ihr hier vorne an hatte
den bug rahmen fällt und dreht das
papier um den wagen herum
die butter gebe ich jetzt in einem
kleinen topf die muss nämlich gleich
sehr heiß sein und die kann ich sie
erstmals schmelzen
jetzt kann ich direkt stärke und mehr
zeit geben sie ist aber vorher durch da
wird der teig etwas lockerer und feine
und ich habe keine klümpchen mit dabei
das habe ich jetzt mit einem schneebesen
unter und in der fachsprache heißt sind
mit ihren das habt ihr vielleicht schon
in fachbüchern oder in anderen büchern
mal gelesen und das ist genau eben
dieser vorgang da muss man es auch ganz
vorsichtig sein so dass keine luft mehr
aus dem teig rausgeschlagen wird
jetzt nehme ich ein bisschen teil und
gebt den teig in die butter rein und für
mich ist es erst mal kurz und so bekommt
datei ist auch gleich keinen job die
butter verbindet sich auch gut mit dem
teig
jetzt kommt diese brutscher teigmasse
zurück zum restlichen teig und wird
nochmal kurz untergehoben
der teig wird jetzt in die vorbereitete
backform eingefüllt den habe ich auf 26
cm durchmesser eingestellt und kann ihn
dann gleich direkt backen
den backofen habe ich jetzt bereits auf
180 grad ober unterhitze vorgeheizt und
da packe ich den teig jetzt für zehn
minuten und backen dann bei 160 grad für
etwa 25 bis 30 minuten weiter
jetzt bereite ich den dunklen wiener
boden zu des mit kakaopulver
ich brauche dafür die gleichen zutaten
wir beim hellen boden also eier zucker
salz und vanille extrakt nur dass ich
hier die zitrone weg und nehme etwas
weniger mehl und stärke und zwar nur 55
gramm jeweils und dafür noch 40 gramm
kakaopulver ungesüßte also bat kakao und
auch butter jetzt zeige ich euch die
version ohne küchenmaschine mit hitze
funktion und zwar mache ich jetzt dafür
ein wasserbad ich habe sie in einem topf
bereits wasser erhitzt und wieder den
herd ausgeschaltet und da stelle ich
eine metallschüssel rein und achtet
dabei darauf dass die schüssel das
wasser auch berührt war kommt jetzt mit
rein dann der zucker und das salz und
wer möchte auch etwas vanille extrakt
und jetzt kann man hier gerne auch noch
weitere aromen zu fügen wir sind zum
beispiel oder je nach dem eben was wie
eine torte man macht jetzt riecht es mit
einem schneebesen kurz durch und muss
diese mischung jetzt auch auf 45 grad
erwärmen lassen sich die eier einfach am
besten aufschlagen
und hier müssen jetzt natürlich dann mit
einem thermometer arbeiten ansonsten
weiß man nicht wenn man die 45 grad
erreicht hat deswegen nehme ich da gerne
immer so ein digitales thermometer
und jetzt ruhig einfach so lange bis die
temperatur erreicht ist
die temperatur erreicht jetzt nehme ich
die eier zucker maße vom herd herunter
und fülle sie direkt in einer
küchenmaschine aber könnte jetzt
natürlich auch mit dem handrührgerät
aufschlagen nur dauert es dann halt
etwas länger
jetzt muss ich die eier zucker masse wie
auch beim hellen tag erst 23 minuten auf
höchster stufe aufschlagen das volumen
rein dann stelle ich die geschwindigkeit
etwas runter so auf etwa 34 und schlagt
sie dann etwa 10 bis 15 minuten kalt und
macht den teig dann fertig wie den
anderen auch
der kuchen sitz fertig und ich zeige
euch jetzt einmal die stäbchen probe und
zwar nämlich dafür immer einen
schaschlikspieß und steckt damit direkt
mit ich ihnen den teig und so bald
nichts mehr dran hängt ist der teig
durch und ich kann ihn heraus nehmen den
torten rahmen kann ich dann direkt lösen
das geht am besten mit einem tortenring
messer
und bevor ich den teig jetzt stürze
lasse ich ihn erst mal zehn minuten
abkühlen den tortenboden kann ich jetzt
stürzen dafür nämlich ein sauberes
geschirr tuch und lege es einmal drüber
und kann dann einen torten retter
darüber legen einmal umdrehen und stand
direkt das blatt papier abziehen so las
ich den kuchenteig immer komplett
abkühlen und verwenden meistern erst am
nächsten tag tage lässt sich der tag
nämlich viel besser durchschneiden und
diesen wieder boden egal ob hell oder
dunkel könnte jetzt weiter verwenden um
beispielsweise torten zu machen ihr
könnt ihr auch für motiv torten nehmen
und ihr könnt sie dann anschließend eben
auch trinken mit etwas alkohol oder mit
etwas saft um so einfach noch ein
bisschen mehr geschmack mit rein zu
bekommen
falls ihr das rezept nach machen wollt
dann geht auf meinem blog auf cds -
block der täter stets noch mal ganz
genau
die helle und die dunkle variante und
falls ihr keinen 26 zentimeter
durchmesser teig machen wollt gibt's
auch auf meinem blog eine umrechnung
tabelle da könnt ihr nämlich die zutaten
dann für eure backform umrechnen
also ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß und
viel erfolg beim nachhaken und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten mal wieder biss dann
tschüss